i got you
[Music]
i'd like to start off asking you guys a
question i like to ask people on dates
instead of asking people for their
zodiac sign because i feel like that can
be really cringy and i love asking this
question because i feel like you can
learn a lot about a person based off
their answer and that is who is your
batman
the guy's been around like 80 years i
feel like we all have a batman that's to
find a part of our lives so briefly tell
us who your batman is and rob i'd love
to start with you because i'm jealous of
the kids coming up now to get to
experience you as their first batman you
actually ask that on thanks
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i mean i weirdly got to try on every
single batman outfit for my uh
screen test to see actually which batman
i was not adam west i popped madame yeah
i was just making sure he got a great
visual
yeah
that's a great laugh and my head
was only the only person who had a large
enough head for me to fit into the
towers it was cleaning it oh really yeah
everyone i did not realize that everyone
else has quite small heads
and uh
but
i didn't fit into that
one it's not really what you're asking
no this is kind of better yeah when i
got into the cli
so because you you could judge it the
most important thing was the cow
i could only fit into clooney's cow but
then his suit i could not fit into
and uh so i kind of had
like a very vulnerable mid section kind
of groin area you're saying clooney was
tight mcgregor no just i i think he's a
little bit bigger
[Laughter]
i swear a couple of them had nipples i
think one of them has like one nipple
[Laughter]
no you know i remember being a kid
and seeing the tim burton
film and when bruce wayne's parents get
killed like
it was awful to watch as a kid it's like
i think it's every kid's fear right it's
like losing their parents so i love that
film
so i guess michael keaton was my first
batman
what about you jeffrey oh it's adam west
100 yeah see your question i think
just
uh dates your date
just you're just going after the age
because i mean i i was you know like
what seven eight years old
and uh
it was after school it was batman it was
batman it was speed racer ultraman
little gilligan's island thrown in
but the batman was uh was adam west and
i mean that was just matt and i talked
about it a bit because you know we look
at it now and it's kind of camp and it's
you know the pastels and all of that
but when you're a kid i mean that was
serious it was serious business it was
serious like you know heroism and
and it was cool it was modern yeah i
remember because it was it was replayed
on english tv yeah i used to watch it
all the time and i never thought i mean
i didn't really know what the difference
was but i mean i thought it was really
serious yeah and the performances are
just i mean says romero and earth kitt
and and burgess meredith and all me and
just like i mean it was just brilliant
brilliant stuff for a kid so yeah that
was like i used to make a little batcave
on the sofa and i kind of you know do my
whole thing and i was well into it well
into it but adam west 100 i love how old
i am
that show still holds up too zoe who's
yours
rob has rob's my batman
batman yeah
will you be my batman
that sounds like valentine's day yes
yes oh yes yeah thank you
and colin who was yours i had two
jeffries adam west and and also paul was
saying tim burton
uh so i'll double dip yeah when i was a
child pre-10 and just come home from
school and watch adam west
in his version and then which wasn't
camp at all of course it wasn't it was
life or death and it was intriguing and
i mean they circle each other every
episode the riddler penguin joker and
catwoman and they just i've watched it
recently with my son and it's
extraordinary how often they all bump
into each other in a broad daylight
and so looking back in that way it's
kind of ridiculous but it was wonderful
at the time and it's still really
enjoyable but then tim burton you know
when i was beginning to feel i suppose
the recognition of certain anxieties and
discomforts as a young man like 13 or 14
or 15 then i related to the world that
tim burton michael keaton's batman and
his his kind of beautiful kind of
awkwardness which
even though he was awkward of course he
had a confidence so it was kind of
almost like wow you can be awkward in
yourself and
rub up against the world
with awkwardness and yet you can have an
inner strength that's that's an
interesting concept to hold as a young
man or a boy becoming yeah it's so
beautifully said and he means so much to
us in like so many different ways which
is what i love i think you were right
about dating too because mine was kevin
conroy batman the animated
that's the action figure i had and rob i
was actually watching an interview you
did years ago where you said that you
were looking at a batman action figure
and you couldn't wrap your head around
the fact that you were batman so i
wanted to know when was the first moment
you truly felt like batman was it when
you put on the suit when you got in the
car
first fight scene
i mean there's two there's there's
two different versions there's one
version where you kind of feel like
batman i mean there's another kind of
realization where you realize you
actually are playing him and i think
like even when i look at the poster
in the back room here i still can't
really understand that it's even
happening like but but there's
definitely definitely moments where
you're kind of
you put on the suit actually to be
honest it was on the uh this the camera
test and when we did it was the first
time i had the full
um
suit on
and people start kind of behaving
differently around you it has such a
kind of totemic power and like
the crew looked a little bit scared i
mean there's something it's really weird
if you don't say anything you're
standing there you're just kind of
just
people get freaked out by it um so yeah
probably on the program the camera test
day yeah people are stoked on this suit
man the way it catches light the way it
accentuates like your enviable jawline
and it feels like it has a lot of
moveability which i think will lend
itself to some really cool fights uh i
wanted to ask you about bruce wayne
because
darwin cook has a batman comic called
batman ego which to me is just
fascinating because he separates batman
and bruce wayne
and they have a conversation with each
other about what it is they actually do
which i think is so interesting because
it's in the same way where we all
struggle with our own egos on a daily
basis so rob did you approach bruce
wayne and batman as two separate people
um
kind of i mean i kind of i love that
comic and uh and there are quite a few
of them when when bruce is kind of
she's kind of having a bit of an
existential crisis and and even the way
he becomes batman i mean literally a bat
smashes through the window and he's like
ah i'm gonna be a bat and like i mean
it's not really a normal kind of guy
and i was and i i got really obsessed
with thinking that there was
there's an element of like mysticism in
it as well and kind of how much power he
kind of imbues and into
the suit i mean he really thinks when he
puts on the suit he's no longer bruce
it's not because there's in other
talents of the story
they kind of really
successfully kind of rationalize why
he's wearing the suit and it's to scare
superstitious criminals and stuff and i
think in this one
kind of what i got from ego and and from
quite a few other comics is um
he he believes it he when he believes
and he puts on the suit
he disappears and i thought it was
interesting to kind of think that
bruce feels
um
as himself
impotent to help anybody and um
and avenge his parents he needs to
completely embrace his alter ego and so
in our telling of the story like bruce
hasn't really got control of his persona
as bruce yet like he's just
he's a recluse that he's a recluse and
he's not he's not the kind of playboy
that we've seen in other tongues of the
story like he's he's a freak he's
funny i don't know he's not necessarily
freak he just doesn't really go out that
much
he's also addressing the episode he's
doing the bat but he kind of he wants
that he wants to be batman the whole
time which is kind of a lot of the
comics are about that when it's kind of
he thinks that that man is his true self
but in this it kind of
uh alludes to it a lot more than usual i
mean he really he doesn't want to do
anything else and um
that was quite interesting he was
interested he's struggling and hasn't
quite made sense in in the way that a
lot of other tellings there's like too
almost too much clarity and like why i'm
doing what i do
and i i get from you and from the film
that
you think you maybe know why you're
doing what you're doing but actually
you're too much seen the thick of that
struggle
that it will be revealed it's almost
like i mean i could talk about all day
whether or not bruce wayne is the actual
mask here but someone who understands
batman i think very intimately is
catwoman played by you
zoe and this is an origin story for
selena which i think is very exciting
for all of us as fans
who who does selena kyle want to be and
like what is it that she understands
about batman
who does she want to be i mean in this
story i don't really know if that's what
she's thinking about you know i think
she really wants to be free from her
past i think in the story you know i
think she's trying to
liberate herself
um from a lot of trauma and a lot of
pain and um you know the cat woman that
we know and love who's really able to
relish and enjoy the chaos she's not
quite there yet you know so
it's a it's a really interesting place
to to meet her and
um i think she really
um
is struck by the connection she has with
batman because i think both of them are
people who never feel seen or connect to
anybody and i think it's a little scary
to meet someone who
affects you the way that we affect each
other yeah there's definitely a vibe
there there's definitely vibes yeah i
could have just said that yeah i have a
thing for strays it's fantastic yeah
that was a last-minute ad
fantastic it's so beautiful really it's
very romantic
and heartfelt i think you also see like
a young woman like fighting for her life
exactly messed up city yeah and and i
think that's
good yeah it's it's um i think it's
refreshing
to not romanticize the character too
much where she's
again
you know just
having a great time being mischievous i
think she really is
a woman trying to survive and that's
something you know we don't see a lot in
these films yeah paul i love that you
brought that up too because zoe i was
reading an interview you did where you
said batman's like the masculine and
catwoman is like the feminine and i
don't want to speak for all women but
personally sometimes i feel like we have
to lead with our masculine so much
especially in the workplace so i wanted
to ask you like how did you get in touch
with your feminine for this role it's a
very vulnerable place to be
yeah
that's a good that's a really good
question you know i think um
it's interesting like the idea of
being in your power right and i think a
lot of us associate power with
masculinity and so often times
as a woman when you want to feel
powerful i think we can imitate
masculine power
and so
i really wanted to allow myself to be
soft and to take my time
and to trust that she's a badass without
having to lead with any kind of bravado
yeah oh love it i can't wait to see your
catwoman really i can't wait to see all
your characters because they're all
unlike any of the versions we've seen in
the previous live actions especially jim
gordon jeffrey i think what's so what
makes me so stoked about this film is
it's a detective story and i feel like
we've just all been craving that from
batman and it feels like gordon and
batman are like partners in this one so
what excited you about bringing this
version of jim gordon to life and how
did that detective story and angle
influence your portrayal of him
well
you know
it's very much a throwback in that way
the film it's a throwback to it's not an
origin story of batman but in some ways
it's kind of an origin story of the
series
in that it begins in detective comics
it's about
mysteries and crying crime solving and
he's the world's greatest detective and
so we really focus on that and it gives
us
gives gordon an opportunity to really be
in the middle of things and you know
he's still um lieutenant gordon not
commissioner so he's on the street
and so
much of what i do is informed by what
rob does but you know so we're
you know it's all people ask going how
does how is this different today it's
different because we're working with rob
you know we're all working together and
working with within matt's vision
and james chinlin's vision uh
of gotham and greg frazier's lighting
and all that's what's different about
what i've done um with this you know
because uh every you know i mean you
know
i've said before but you know gary
oldman is one of the most influential
actors that's out there for me
personally wow i saw sid and nancy
it just blew my head open to the
possibility of what we were able to do
in terms of
uh freedom and um intensity
and just like it just you know just
opened my head up my head up
so i have met you know massive massive
respect for the actors who come before
and play this role but what
differentially differentiates me from
them is i get to work with these folks
you know yeah so let's talk about these
folks and who makes up the gotham
criminal underworld paul this is the
first time riddler is at the center of a
batman live-action movie in over 25
years
i'm sure fans are wondering how good is
he at wordle
but i want to know
what drew you to the riddler like what
did you read and see in the script or
you're like i want to play this guy
well i was totally
surprised and blown away by the script
uh
and you know this day and age you have
to ask why
why are we going to reinterpret
you know the batman right and
uh right from the get-go of matt's
script he had a really clear point of
view uh of of what he was bringing to
this film
you could see the film as you read it
and
something that i was really
moved by
was
that he was exploring the two sides of
trauma maybe and you know the batman is
born of trauma right bruce wayne losing
his parents and
and some people are able to
take that and use it as fuel
and sometimes that fuel can lead towards
something potentially good and i think
sometimes people take that fuel and and
it takes them i guess i was really
interested also in the mask and the idea
that
a vigilante in our world you know we can
see what we we often can see what we
want to see
and
uh
even though to a lot of people the
batman stands for good i can tell you
that i as my character
saw him representing exactly what i
wanted to as a as a great source of
inspiration and and power
and so there was some
awesome gray in the morality uh of
gotham and the idea of good and bad
just felt super complex
and thrilling and deep and uh
and i i mean i i was i'm still so
excited about it oh well we're so
excited to see it but speaking of
inspiration colin
let's talk about penguin because i was
looking at a dossier of like all the
roles you've had in your life and
they're just so fantastical and when i
think people think of penguin they think
of like umbrellas and danny devito so
how did you take this character
and how did you conceive penguin into
your own version while still maintaining
all the things that this character's
like endured
and what was it like having that suit on
like how are how are you guys reacting
to him like with that it was fun it was
that we had a day
i read the script first i look i loved
matt's films
um
and
i think he's an extraordinary filmmaker
and i think however large
a scale he may present his films in
there's always something incredibly
immediate and personal at the core of
his films
um which is a testament to just his true
interest not just as a painter and as a
filmmaker and somebody who presents
these really beautiful aesthetics
through
the the medium of film but somebody who
really is concerned with the human
condition matt as a man and an artist so
when i read the script i found all those
things that i had recognized in his
previous work were alive and well and
presented of course in a new way and in
a new world a world that's very familiar
to us all as either comic book lovers or
film lovers of of batman as a character
but was incredibly new and original and
so i was so gripped by the script and i
just wanted to be part of it and i
didn't know what i could do with it
until when i read penguin i was kind of
i didn't i found it hard to find out
where he was and his trajectory as a man
and his trajectory as a criminal because
i know he's the penguin that i felt we
found was very aspirational had dreams
about power
and dreams about getting uh out from
beneath the shadow of his own um
what he perceived as his own
disfigurement and how he had been judged
as well for looking maybe the way he
looks and for being the way he is so he
very gingerly compensates i don't even
say overcompensates but is compensated
through the use of violence and his
street smarts in a world that's been
very hard for him to deal with so all
those things were there having talked to
matt and the one thing matt always
wanted to be aware of with this film and
i think it's really really clear when
you see it is everything is grounded
everything is believable everything is
practically reachable through your
understanding as a human being and
physically as possible as well um but
the the makeup and the thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that was fun so i honestly when i read
the script i was kind of like all the
[ __ ] that i just said but then i read
the script i also was gone i don't
really know what to do with and then
matt showed me mike marino's design
for what the penguins visage was gonna
look like and as soon as he showed me
the design i swear to god
as the second he showed me the design i
got so and the script is fantastic it
was my
myopia shortcoming as an actor that i
was struggling to see how i would find
my way in with the five or six scenes
that penguin had when i saw what mike
mourinho created with the makeup and i
just got so excited and we had a makeup
test out in warner brothers studios one
day and there was eight or nine people
there you know someone to do the teeth
someone to do the wig someone to do this
something to do for people who are
applying things and it was so exciting
and we were all just on the same page
there was like eight nine ten of us
there and we were all
and i'd done a bit of dialect work so as
soon as the makeup went on the dialogue
came in a little bit it was just fun it
was just so much fun it was such a and
so many people
it didn't feel like my creation alone
like i'm just part of the team that
brought that stuff to life you know
starting with matt and his his genesis
of of
what he wrote on the page wow well after
hearing that i mean we're so excited to
see him in this fall and in the
spin-offs
i'm not even there
the fact that we're even getting more
from that character and from yours
jeffrey and also your laughs have just
been killing me in this whole interview
can i say i love your laugh so much oh
my life yeah
i love that we're just getting more in
all these spin-off series but speaking
of more i want to ask you a question rob
that i think everyone's going to be
thinking when they walk out of the
theater
how long do you want to play batman
yeah i mean it was so fun doing it i
mean i'm kind of i'm down to do it as
many times as people want to see it
really like i mean i've got to get this
one out first
but yeah like i mean
i've talked to matt about the idea of
doing a trilogy and uh
and that would be wonderful i mean i
really really enjoyed the process and
it's such a fun character to play and
yeah it'll be that'd be lovely lovely
there's so much room for this batman to
grow today yes really big time i think
it needs that this is what it is
in this big time
he's a giant party boy no i i'm really
that is something i think but i think
because you're such a recluse bruce such
a recluse in not available
[Laughter]
this is a big deal for you guys and when
we do things that are a big deal in life
there's the anticipation of it then
there's the doing it and then there's
the coming out on the other side of it
which is where you guys are now but i
feel like we're in this sweet spot right
now where you guys are done filming but
you haven't shared it with the world yet
so i just want to capture right now how
are you feeling in this moment and we'll
just go down the line thanks zoe yeah
honestly i'm saying
i i i'm excited to see
i don't usually get
a bit of a grump sometimes when it comes
to films and stuff that i do and
and i can easily kind of be disparaging
you know but um
try not to i'm really i'm genuinely
excited about this i'm just excited to
be a part of it and i'm excited to have
worked with these actors and i'm excited
to be in the world that that matt
envisioned and that was creative
production design and lit by greg and
all of it i'm
really excited to be a part of it yeah
truly yeah it's a really it's a really
special moment you know i think you know
even if we continue to make these films
for the you know this moment will never
happen again for the first film to come
out and there's something bittersweet
about it because
it's not ours anymore you know i think
when you put art into the world it just
it stops being
um our little you know creation and um
so you know it's the end of something
and also the beginning of something and
it's it's really special
yeah and i think uh
after a kind of very difficult strange
period to be a part of something which
has
this fan base it's still has such an
anticipation for it they're very very
excited you kind of really feed off it
like i mean it's like we're in a period
where there's hardly any movies coming
out in the cinema at the moment and like
to have this level of anticipation
it's just it's lovely and it kind of
makes you
it gives you hope for cinema gives you
hope for the movies that come afterwards
and um
and yeah it's just a it's a real
privilege to be a part of it i got so
excited seeing spider-man yeah you know
yeah very different films and all that
whatever um but really excited i got
caught up in the global energy it was my
awareness that people all around the
world were going with their kids or
their friends and their lovers or
whatever and really having this
experience cultural moment i have no
expectations for how many people are
going to like this love it not like it
have a gripe with it or any of that but
i i do believe and i was saying it to
matt when matt finished the film i sent
him a text and i said i i hope he
because he's map worked i i don't know
how the man is saying oh my god i kind
of worried about it i'm still worried
i said you need to go into a foreign
that you're
going to move and bring a lot of
entertainment and joy into so many like
millions of people's lives even if it
does badly he's going to do that in
millions of people's lives well i think
the thing though um
particularly about this you know making
this film we made it over a long period
of time you know in kind of you know in
unusual circumstances but circumstances
that we've all around the world
experienced
and
there's also a sense now that we can't
trust certain things there's a sense of
uncertainty and a sense of fluidity
but with these characters
these films this story about 80 years
characters that are known loved
um
audiences people yearn for them because
they trust them there's something that
you can hold on to even the riddler i
trust that i know what the ruler is
going to be i trust that he's going to
be the riddler and i think there's
something
there's something i've you know as i
kind of take in the passion that fans
have for this you know as you kind of
sense it
and i think it's it's it's something
around that it's something that
um
in a shifting world at a shifting time
people can hold on to with both hands
and so um yeah i'm pretty stoked that we
can you know finally
give over to them what we've
been churning out you know over the
years or over the year and a half or
however long it was that we've worked on
it but uh yeah and finally just let it
out there and hope people
trust it and i help people go to the
theater i if you're able to go to the
theater this is a movie you will have
the rest of your life to watch it at
home but this film this kind of film is
why big screens exist you know so i
really urge people to to if they are
able to
to go see this in the cinema because
it's an experience and to be alive in
this moment to have the opportunity to
see it to see it on a screen that big is
pretty special it's really amazing
couldn't have said it better myself guys
tickets are on sale right now i think i
speak for everyone when i say
congratulations and thank you and let
the countdown begin cool
[Music]
you